and now I never quite understand this
but I read somewhere Britt that you
ought to learn you actually taught a
moviestar run yeah I mean they tried for
like five minutes I can work with that
on you oh yes I have it's a true thing
yeah our stunt coordinator Rob Alonso at
one point he was like you know if you're
gonna be in this movie you're gonna be
running a lot there if you want to work
on it there's the thing called the movie
star run because he worked with Tom
Cruise a lot on the Mission Impossible
I'm telling you this is a real thing
that exists does matter thing isn't it
yeah
yeah but it's like high knees and you
have to get you have to get the face
work
that one right there that one right
there
[Music]
[Applause]
now I understand but you know her you
got to do big fights I do ever done big
fights before on film no now we did have
a big fight which and we did are we
trained we got we got naked now we got
physical on judo mats we were taking put
through our paces he's in very very good
nick by the way however the hazard of
that was I at you there was a moment I
threw a punch at this man I'm wearing a
big sort of chunky signet ring and I
threw this punch and he went dunk into
thee or it went thunk or actually it
went but I missed him by the thickness
of a skin cell I could have damaged that
the hallways everyone good noise I think
we could do better I was this close
it was us it was it was I would not have
been very popular with anybody
[Music]
you